get at it is
almost
hi everyone my name is Valentin and I'm
here on behalf of community language
cooperative and I'm here to provide and
guarantee your commitment to language
Justice language Justice is a type of
simultaneous interpretation that seeks
to create spaces in which no one
language is dominant spaces in which
everyone can participate with the
language of their heart
so to achieve this objective we will be
using zoom's interpretation feature what
you will see in a couple of minutes is
that I need a little button that looks
like a globe will appear on the bottom
bar of your screen on that same bar
where you have the mic the video the
chat and I love those other buttons
it'll be towards your right hand when
you see this button come up go ahead and
click on it and select either English or
Spanish as both the language that you
will be listening into and speaking into
if you're joining this meeting on a
phone or on a tablet you will find the
same options by clicking on the button
with the three little dots on the lower
right hand corner of your screen this
button reads more
a quick reminder for those of you that
will be using English as their main
language for today's meeting Spanish is
20 to 25 longer than English so please
be aware of your speed and if there's
any text that hasn't been translated in
advance of the meetings in PowerPoints
or elsewhere in the chat box wherever
please
um read out loud the main parts or we
suggest that you read out loud most of
the texts so that I can interpret it in
the other language so that no one misses
any any of the content if you're going
to be using acronyms please uh spell
them out the first couple of times to
avoid any confusion among the listeners
or myself if you have any questions or
any issues whatsoever with this
technology please let the whole group
know by means of the chat box
foreign
thank you so much for having me here we
can go ahead and start the
interpretation channels
yeah and I'd like to I see the first on
my screen is Seraphina if you'd like to
come off mute introduce ourselves we
have Seraphina Aaron Reynolds Ellie and
Aaron joining us as our guest speakers
thank you Anna so glad to be here with
you all good afternoon
I'm Sarah Fina Lombardi I come from a
long line of subsistence farmers and I'm
still farming in Chimayo New Mexico with
my family I used to be president of the
Santa Fe Farmers Market helped found a
local vegetable Growers Co-op and for
the last 10 years I've been serving the
New Mexico Aztec Association as our
program director and I came to this work
specifically to help our local
indoorspano community's access uh nrcs
and FSA programs that's the Farm Service
Agency for FSA and nrcs's natural
resource conservation service
um I got a high tunnel through a nrcs
program back in 2011 and since then I've
been really happy to help others access
these opportunities
glad to be here and I'll pass it back to
you on app
foreign
if you'd like to introduce yourself
uh good afternoon and good morning
everyone my name is Aaron Reynolds and I
am a resource conservationist with the
natural resources conservation service
or nrcs that I'm going to use on a
regular basis I am based out of
Albuquerque New Mexico and I manage the
equip program the Environmental Quality
incentive program and our emergency
Watershed Protection Program
but my position is just specifically in
the state of New Mexico and it doesn't
vary in other states I have other
counterparts in those states that do the
exact same thing I do
foreign
er
um and really amazing co-founder of an
organization that I I draw a lot of
inspiration from Ellie who's joining us
from California
hey everyone thanks so much for
including me my name is Ellie iGo I join
you from San Diego
um and the land of the luisano
um
and or also known as the payomet and
that we are fortunate to rent our land
from and exciting to talk to you about
today
um today about nrcs and other programs
that we've used to make our farm more
resilient
thank you Ellie and then uh who I work
the closest with Aaron
um is our water director in helping to
kick off this Workshop series
foreign yeah thanks Anna hi all nice to
see you all thanks for being here as
Anna said
um my name's Aaron I am the water
director for the national young Farmers
Coalition uh so I'll be just sharing a
little bit at the end about some other
ways to plug in with our work and get
more um information like this one but
excited to be learning more about these
nrcs programs
thank you
and without further Ado I am going to
share just really quickly so you all can
all see the Run of show today our agenda
um we will dedicate a lot of time today
to question and answers if you have
questions along the way for speakers and
it's relevant something that's top of
Mind feel free to put those questions in
the chat uh I will make sure if the
speakers can address that question
immediately that that is a question
um that I'll keep as a log and we can
come back to and during the question and
answer part of our agenda
um and I will also be helping our
speakers keep track of time and keep us
moving
um so very quickly and then Seraphina is
going to get us started
um engaging all of you with a few
questions
are
agenda is going to start with Seraphina
and
then we're gonna have a few presentation
slide decks shared that will all be sent
to you later
um in an email so any of the information
that you
see today you will have access to later
on we will also make sure to share our
contact information that way if you have
any questions that don't get addressed
that you will have a way to follow up
with each of us after
um so today we've done our welcome and
introductions
um I'm going to go into why nrcs share a
little about who who and what nrcs does
uh here's some testimonials from Ellie
um
really give an overview of some of the
existing programs in nrcs then we'll
have time for question and answers and
introduce our larger water campaign at
the end and wrap up so without further
Ado I am going to stop sharing my screen
and hand the mic over to Serafina
thank you Anna I got the mic
so um I have to give a big shout out to
all the New Mexico people out there I
saw Miss Adriana I see some Samia people
what's up Mexico's special we're all
special on this call but in Mexico's
extra special
um so I'm really curious for all of us
to get a little sense of what experience
anyone here has had with any USDA
programming in this bucket so the United
States Department of Agriculture is the
big department that the nrcs natural
resource conservation service is under
um and so I'm hoping folks can use the
raise hand function which is in your
reactions if you see a little smiley
face emoji you can click on it and it'll
give you a raised hand in the lower hand
so we're going to go up and down a few
times
um but just wanted to jump in and say
who here has registered signed up with
the Farm Service Agency
yeah let us know right on so that's the
FSA Farm Service Agency it's an acronym
that the need to know in the
conversation we're having and they're
the first step to being able to access
nrcs programming if you don't sign up
and get a farm and track number with the
Farm Service Agency and there's a local
office in not all counties but many
counties and I'm sure we'll throw up in
the chat a link to how to find those
um you can apply for any nrcs programs
and there's a whole other bucket of
support and assistance that comes to the
Farm Service Agency that we're not going
to talk about but good for you everybody
who signed up you can lower your hand
awesome congratulations you have taken
you've opened the door to Opportunity by
doing so you've also ensured that your
farm gets invited to be counted in the
AG census which in New Mexico we're
super undercounted as small world
largely indoorspano farms and just like
with the regular senses it can impact
the resources that go to our regions so
there's an equity aspect and
um you know for this group beginning
Farmers we want beginning farmers and
ranchers counted too so
I think you got my point on FSA
here's the next question
how many here have ever applied
to nrcs it doesn't mean that you
received a grant or it's not a grant
you're not supposed to use that word
cost assistance but okay right on my
dogs are gonna go crazy now great timing
neighbors dropping by and honking at me
and that's all they're gonna get is dog
bark
one second
foreign
okay I have a taped to a room that's
further away from the animals and
visitors pardon the interruption that's
part of just how we roll in our rural
community stopping by for visits
um so I see a bunch of you have applied
it would be really cool if folks want to
throw in the chat some of the practices
that you've applied for and that's a
term that nrcs uses to describe are you
applying for irrigation practices High
tunnel practices soil Health initiatives
um Aaron's going to go way deeper into
what some of those options are and the
cost share and reimbursement type of
on-farm improvements
um right on high tunnel that's that was
my it's a really good point of entrance
to nrcs programs is the high tunnel work
so right on and feel free to keep
sharing those because I think it's
really helpful from a peer-to-peer
experience to see what other people are
interested in and what potentially is
working for them
um and I think Aaron will touch on what
some of the most popular programs are
but if we let him know what we're really
interested in he might be able to best
speak to some of those programs too
so
um and that last question I'm going to
ask well main last question so you can
lower your hands if you put them up
congratulations on applying
um way to go and then the final one to
have you received
um a contract or implemented an nrcs
program and so if you want to raise your
hand if you've implemented one we can
see who the the veterans are in the
crowd yeah we got some folks with
knowledge so you guys could be
co-hosting with us up here and what's up
CJ
um explaining your experience uh right
on good work and one of the things you
all have probably found
um and I know I experienced is that once
you implement a practice and your
neighbors find out about it you become
an emissary for these programs and it
just multiplies after that so my mentor
I moved to New Mexico to work with Don
Bustos who's a Visionary farmer in our
region and he was like the first guy in
the north to do high tunnels and then he
did them and I did them and they're just
like multiplied and we see it in our
arid
um high altitude climate as like a
climate change adapting to seasonal
change
um
strategy
so we've had a lot of fun and I love the
plastic part but we've had a lot of fun
replicating that and creating a lot of
farmer's market opportunities for folks
um and then lastly if you haven't
applied and you don't even know what the
programs are but just you know what's
the kind of support you're looking for
on your farm that you think brought you
to this Workshop you know what what is
it that you have a need for
um that you're hoping nrcs might be able
to address and if you want to throw that
in the chat oh my gosh it's so cool
another dumb was still spin he says
woohoo that's like his woohoo by the way
if you know
um
and he changed my life I wouldn't even
be here in this whole chapter of my life
if it wasn't for Dom boosters total
homage
anyhow that's a longer story than we're
here for today
so
um thank y'all for your input and your
sharing and just like your engagement
like you're doing it and way to show up
to his Workshop just to get any tips and
tricks you can
um I want to talk briefly about why the
New Mexico a second sensation and if you
don't know where to secure that's a
traditional irrigation canal that's
Community run we're a local political
government and I'll leave it at that
um but we work with Farmers across the
state to protect our water rights our
cultural traditions and grow healthy
food for our families
and
um we're doing this work really honoring
and as a part of the legacy of Southern
black farmers who stood up and addressed
Injustice systemic discrimination within
the USDA
I'm the United States Department of
Agriculture
excluding a number of different
um communities and in New Mexico that
was largely indo-ispano farmers and
ranchers in the south in the case the
Pickford case that was settled in 2010
that was black Farmers across the
country but especially in the South and
so many communities including women at
times have been historically
marginalized marginalized and kept out
of these programs and that funding and
support for our farms and ranches was
denied anime gets a grant from the USDA
to do Outreach into historically
underserved communities and nrcs has
changed a lot even in the last decade or
two and we have some awesome folks in
our local County offices who look and
experience more of what our communities
look like as well as energy as being a
national org so we have movement from
across the country with folks who
understand and are allied with local
farms and ranches so for us it's part of
our social justice mission
to ensure that our communities who have
in so many ways been historically
disenfranchised feel like they have a
seat at the table and have access to
these programs so we do a lot of what we
call hand-holding to get people their
Farm Service
um registration done and to apply for
these programs and to some
lesser degree Implement them we also we
just went through historic and tragic
Wildfire season in New Mexico and we
know with climate change whether you
know you're in the Midwest and you're
getting flooding these climate disasters
are coming and they're coming hard and
they're hitting farmers and ranchers
particularly hard
um
so we realized more than we ever had
that ewp program emergency Watershed
program Aaron referenced you you want to
be a part of the system if you want to
access a lot of the Disaster Assistance
if you lose livestock you need to be
registered to the Farm Service Agency
for the livestock indemnification
program and I could go on so registering
with Farm Service Agency is an important
step to being prepared for disasters
um and for some degree of relief but
also for some programs that can help
mitigate and make us more resilient to
disasters that come
um and in general we think there's a lot
of great strategies we're for anything
that helps our local farms be more
viable for us
um growing food for Community is a very
deep value and something we really still
depend on in Northern New Mexico
um
but we also think the practice is nrcs
office offers can be useful in climate
change adaptation overall
um
I think the last few things that I would
mention is that it is paperwork it is
bureaucracy it's really none of our
favorite things to be in the system and
have to kind of follow
um the specs
um that are exterior to us but I really
encourage you all to explore the
offerings to reach out to your local
County offices both of the Farm Service
Agency and the nrcs
in order to establish relationships
create a site visit that's the number
one after you do FSA it's all about
getting a site visit so you can learn
more about what might work on your farm
your local nrcs rep is an ally and
someone who's there to give you
technical assistance whether or not you
want to apply for any programs to get
feedback to get support
um
and so we just really encourage everyone
to know the ins and outs of a contract
before they're signing it I have lots of
thoughts on that
um and you know then just go ahead and
once you feel confident jump into feet
first but I think one of the best things
is connecting with folks locally who've
done a similar program and gaining
lessons learned from them
um so with that I just wish all of you a
bountiful happy safe growing season that
you find all the resources that you need
and if you are a farmer a Rancher
um often a sick in New Mexico the anime
A is here to provide more detailed
technical assistance I'm looking forward
to the rest of the meeting and
potentially supporting with any
questions you all have and now you've
seen my bathroom while we're at it too
foreign
if you could please put your contact
information in the chat
um we also have a New Mexico nrcs staff
here Aaron who's going to share a little
more for those of you who may not be as
familiar with who the natural resources
conservation Services is and what they
do
all righty thank you so I'll go ahead
and share my screen
all right well uh again good morning
good afternoon everybody
um again my name is Aaron Reynolds and I
am a resource conservationist with the
natural resource conservation Service uh
based out of Albuquerque for this first
portion that I'm going to present on
it's mainly going to be around what nrcs
is and what our two major programs we
like to see I know there's been a lot of
mentioned of the ewp or the emergency
Watershed Protection Program and
um at the end of the presentation I can
mention what that program is because it
is significantly different than any of
our other programs that we offer to
people and it's mainly based around
natural disasters
um fires and floods and things of that
nature that pose a threat to human life
and property but at this point in time
I'm not going to go too much into depth
on it
so my contact information is on the
slides and these slides will be shared
with everyone but I can also put my
contact information in the chat for
people
um so
um just giving a brief introduction
about myself
um I've been with the agency going on 12
years now I've actually worked in
multiple States so I'm originally from
Wisconsin where I grew up on a small
farm and started within RCS in the
midwest then I actually moved to
Colorado and I worked out on the Eastern
Plains on more conventional agricultural
operations and then I moved to New
Mexico where I eventually ended up in
Albuquerque as a resource
conservationist or program manager
so uh for those who don't know nrcs is
an agency within the United States
Department of Agriculture so this is a
federal agency and um very commonly we
work with a lot of conservation
districts locally in areas and other
organizations that assist farmers and
ranchers to improve their operations but
nrcs or the natural resources
conservation service provides landowners
with technical assistance and a vice
advice for their land specifically and
one of the things I always like to
mention to nrcs staff and also the
landowners is that those local
landowners know their land better than
anybody else you know we just come in
and try to help them improve their
Landing continue what they're trying to
achieve on that land so nrcs provides
common technical goal assistance in the
area will assess resource resources and
then we'll also come in with practice
design and resource monitoring
all of this is done throughout the what
we call the conservation planning
process and
um you know it's a very fluid motion and
it changes depending on what the needs
of that landowner are so that's just
briefly where nrcs comes in is that
we're a scientific scientific and
Technical based agency that will assist
uh you know landowners and again I'll
get it more into the details of who's
eligible and what are the requirements
for our programs but there is financial
assistance to implement a lot of these
programs
so um for those who don't know um nrcs
used to be called The Soil Conservation
service and the roots of nrcs is
um based in the 1930s and the Dust Bowl
so if people
um can recall back to their history
courses the Dust Bowl was a time in
American history where there was a lot
of tillage occurring and soil in the air
and
um you know the president at that time
so FDR actually saw the need to
implement
conservation Nationwide and thus that's
how nrcs was born
um nrcs has evolved and I should say
changed tremendously in recent years and
now our Focus has expanded to
um soil water air plant and animals
there are soil resource concerns so um
it's a much different agency and it's a
much broader agency than what it used to
be
um so
as mentioned I'm gonna the two cost
share programs that we have through nrcs
are the equip program and CSP so in
simple terms um
because we don't have enough time to go
in depth on all these programs so I'm
just going to give a brief summary of
what each one of these programs are and
then we can build from there so the
first program that I'm going to mention
is the Environmental Quality incentive
program
and uh we call it short we call it equip
as its acronym and it provides Technical
and financial assistance to producers to
address a natural resource concerns
deliver environmental benefits through
conservation practices to protect soil
water air and other natural resources
concerns and in simple terms the way you
look at this is equip treat specific
concerns and I'm going to provide a few
scenarios of how equip is used and then
eventually our um
guest presenter that has actually
implemented this can describe how they
installed these practices so
as mentioned eqip is very specific you
have one resource concern that you're
trying to treat so
um one of the common uh comments that I
saw was a lot of people utilize them for
high tunnels and when high tunnels are
installed which um I guess real briefly
what a high tunnel is a high tunnel is a
structure that is covered in plastic
that extends your growing season so you
can start for example your cool season
crops earlier or get some of those warm
season crops to go a little later
depending on what you need them
so through eqip
um you could receive cost share on the
high tunnel itself the irrigation inside
that high tunnel there are some specific
requirements on the irrigation and
what's needed to meet the install and
irrigation but you could have the
irrigation you could have nutrient
management which is testing your soil
and get an idea of you know how many how
much of nutrients do I need in my soil
to achieve my desired yield goal and
then also
um there's things like Pest Management
to manage disease and other pests that
could damage you and then also one
called irrigation Water Management to
better manage your water usage on your
property and you know that's just one
specific example of how equip could be
used for this
um you know eventually I'll talk about
some of the land uses that equip could
be used on you know because it can range
from forestry can range from rangeland
pasture crop land so there's a it's a
variable program that gives you a lot of
flexibility depending on what your
specific needs are for this program
um
then the next program I'm going to
mention and this isn't one of the
programs I manage specifically
but it's called our conservation
stewardship program and simply put the
conservation stewardship program
the goal of the program is to build on
good conservation that you're already
doing so you're far if you're already
testing your soil if you're already
monitoring your water it assists those
producers to take it to a Next Level and
do more advanced forms of those
conservation systems and specifically on
the CSP program that makes it unique is
in order to be eligible for CSP
um you have to sign up for five years at
one time equip doesn't have that
requirement equip can be a one and done
up to 10 years to get your work done but
you won't be tied into the program
through equip
um and then
that's going to be just a pretty good
summary of the programs um eventually I
will talk about some of the eligibility
of the programs and what all goes into
um actually signing up
so I'll go ahead and hand it off to the
next presenter
all right well I'm just gonna jump in
then
um and say hello to everybody I think
I'm next is that right
um all right so my name is Ellie for
those of you that weren't on the call
yet
um I'm from solidarity farm and
um I am going to share my screen so that
you guys can see some pictures
of
um what we do
[Music]
all right
so what I'm excited to talk to you today
is is how we've leveraged nrcs and
combined it with other resources to make
it really work for our farm
um and just want to start by saying that
you know solidarity Farm is a modest
sized Farm
um we prefer we produce um Diversified
fruits and vegetables and we collaborate
with our neighbors
um through a small farm Distribution
Company called food shed
um and you know we
um
well we Farm probably at any given time
about five out of those 10 acres and
we've been doing it for about 10 years
um so I'm going to start just by telling
you guys a story about a really
important year which was 2017.
um we you know had just really gotten
our feet under us and had had crops in
the ground and we're selling
commercially and our kids were involved
on the farm
um and we had a heat event that was
about 122 degrees following a winter of
severe freezing and
um we understood that if we didn't get
serious about
um really investing in our soil and
figuring out how to be more resilient
that we were not going
um to be able to continue farming and we
really wanted our kids to to see that
you know you can adapt to challenges
um and that you have to adapt in order
in order to survive so that was really
our our impetus and so we came up with
these four goals
um and I also really quick want to give
a shout out about that time
um we had a
um a intern or an apprentice come to
stay on the farm named Andy Williamson
who's on the call today
um who really pushed us also to to try
out some of these practices so
um I just want to acknowledge Him and
how important he was to us
um but we decided that if we wanted to
keep farming we really need to needed to
invest in four things right we needed to
keep our soil covered we needed to
improve water delivery efficiency we
needed to reduce evaporation that was
caused by wind and we needed to buffer
against cold and heat events with better
infrastructure and and that's a picture
of the barn that was toppled by the
winds that we get these winds called
Santa anas out in in San Diego
and so
um we really you know it was that same
year that that Barn fell down
um and so just sharing that the impacts
um that pushed us were pretty severe
I realize I'm talking too quickly I'm
going to slow down for interpretation
um and so in our need in our desire to
address these four
um these four issues we looked around
for allies and resources
um and obviously today we're gonna um
we're talking about nrcs
um but I just want to acknowledge that
there were three other resources that we
we really relied on one is called the
healthy soils program
um which is a California state program
uh zero food print which is a private
Foundation that leverages money for um
through restaurants
um for regenerative agriculture
and then the coastal conservancy and I
just want to point out that you know we
need as Farmers we need to to leverage
all of these resources and find out
what's happening in our area because
there really isn't a one-size-fit-all
program
um that can help us get the job done
so here are the practices that we have
implemented
with an nrcs conservation equip Grant we
have been able to put in hedgerows and
wind breaks and we've improved our
irrigation efficiency so we used a lot
of lay flat to move the water all the
way across our farm and we were able
within our CS funds to put those pipes
underground and get you know um new new
Outlets closer to the fields that we
were working in
um and uh two high tunnels and in in our
first round of equip
um our healthy soils Grant
um from California Department of food
and agriculture let us address cover
cropping and reducing tillage on our
farm
zero food print brought in the compost
that we needed
and the coastal Conservancy
um helped us to or supported our
perennial some of our perennial
transition and allowed us to use native
more drought tolerance seed in our cover
crop which was really important to
Southern California but wasn't something
that was affordable given that the nrcs
practice really covered you know cheaper
seed like barley
foreign so some of the challenges
um to consider words of wisdom for
things that we learned
um as short-term renters our landlords
had to agree to facilitate this process
um we were really grateful that our
landlords saw the benefit and they LED
on this
um we found that nrcs was busy our local
office was busy and we had to be
persistent to get our first meeting
um
and this is the part that I think is
really important for smaller scale farms
and I I saw in the chat when we were
getting started that people are already
kind of aware of this but
um you know a lot of these programs are
cost reimbursement and so it requires
really thoughtful planning and
partnership
um to really think about how you're
gonna Fork out the money for these
practices and then wait for
reimbursement
um and I thought it was really
interesting that nrcs could not tell us
how much something might cost to
actually Implement in our area and they
really could only tell us what the
reimbursement rate was
um and so that was a little intimidating
um because you know you're getting into
it Without Really knowing what how
expensive everything's going to be so do
your homework and build a budget for
yourself and don't assume that the cost
is actually going to cover what you need
for your area
and the other thing is that your local
nrcs office may not have the expertise
that you need in-house so we live in an
area that's very
um it's full of citrus and avocado
farmers and so our local technical
advisors are really great at Citrus and
avocado but they don't have a lot of
knowledge about row crops and so you
need to Advocate that your nrcs folks
reach outside of their comfort zone and
and to other Ally you know other staff
in nrcs who have that expertise
and then finally you need to account for
specialized equipment needs as you apply
for the practice so something like if
you're putting in cover crop and you're
reducing tillage you might need access
to a no-till seed drill
um but you you know you don't want to or
can't afford to go out and buy one just
for the practice right or you might need
to rent scaffolding to be able to put up
your high tunnel or you might need a
mulch spreader
um that that you don't quite have yet so
really think about what you actually
need to implement and if it's even
available in your area
so ways to overcome some of these
barriers I do want to say that bringing
you know advocating and bringing that
nrcs person out early
um and then trusting the process
um is is really important
um don't do too much homework before you
actually bring them out to your farm
um you can ask a resource Conservation
District or other ta providers in your
area to connect you with a mentor
another farmer who's done this work
before
um I think is really would be really
really helpful and advised
um and you can advocate for overlapping
your practices so the field Prep Plus
the irrigation plus the planting so that
you can maximize the reimbursement
um and make sure you can actually cover
your costs
um and this one I think is really
important
um to overcome that barrier of cost
reimbursement you can find a lending
partner that understands the nrcs
program so I noticed someone was here
from farmlink today California farmlink
or even the Farm Service Agency if you
have an NRC if you have a nrcs equip
contract you should be able to get a
loan right to match that contract and
then when you get paid back by nrcs you
could use that money to pay back the
loan now the terms and the length and
all that is something to consider but it
could be a really great opportunity to
build your credit and to and to make
those two sort of programs mesh together
and then finally you can look for
contractors
um that can that you can pay with nrcs
funds to help you install the practice
so for example this is a picture
um of a gentleman from Fresno so
Fresno's Way North in California we had
to pay him to drive his no-till seed
drill all the way down because one
didn't exist to do our cover cropping
practice in San Diego
um but he had the expertise and he just
busted it out and it actually ended up
being more affordable than if we had
tried to figure out how to broadcast it
or do it ourselves so definitely look
for people who can help you with the
practices
um because we're farmers and and really
implementing this practice these
practices is all about our bottom line
um I wanted to share some of the impact
that this programs have had for us
um we have definitely seen a reduction
in losses during extreme weather events
um because of the practices that we've
implemented
we've seen our soil organic matter
increase from about the you know the
normal threshold which is about one
percent to seven percent in some of the
areas that we've really been applying
these soil building techniques
um that additional soil organic matter
has a huge impact
um on reducing our water bill
and
um the hedgerows also have had a big
impact in reducing the wind that's
directly hitting the beds that are
behind them and that also has an impact
on reducing our summer water bill
we've also seen improved pollination
rates and yields near the hedgerows
although we're just really starting to
be able to monitor that
as our hedgers are getting bigger
um and we've seen this is a big one
we've seen improved infiltration and
reduced flooding during Heavy Rain
events
and we've seen Financial gains from the
season extension that our high tunnels
bring that's really a huge one and why I
think Kai tunnels are the most popular
or one of the most popular nrcs
practices
and then finally you know really
investing into bringing this diversity
onto our farm gives us an opportunity to
bring education and other types of
activities onto the farm so this is an
herbalism class for kids
um and and just wanted to kind of share
that um there are sort of benefits
outside of just the economic ones
um to your community
so I'll close with that this is my
contact information
um and happy to you know kind of connect
and answer any questions you all might
have
wow congratulations those are some
really huge successes to uplift
um and more specifically wanted to go
into a few of those programs some that
solidarity Farms using others that
you've heard mentioned
um and also if you're having any trouble
keeping track of the different acronyms
being thrown around I did post in the
chat uh key uh acronym sheet as well as
steps for receiving USDA assistance and
then we're going to pass it back to
Aaron to to go into more specifics
great thank you and Ella that was great
to hear that story and hear the local
benefits and your goals being met on
that operation
um real quick before I get into the
presentation
um I'm a big fan of soil health I like
hearing that you're implementing soil
health and helping the system just reach
its natural state because our soil is so
unhealthy at this point so that's great
to hear you're you know reaching for
those goals to improve your soil which
ultimately is going to make your
pocketbook a lot bigger as well so
um that's very great to hear
so um
I'll bring up my slides again
um and I Ellie was talking about the
high tunnels this was a high tunnel I
actually worked on in New Mexico
um in Southwest in the Gila that we
installed for him and you can see the
benefit this is having for him
specifically so
um what I'm gonna review today is I'm
going to briefly review the
application process through nrcs there
is a link that does go a bit more in
depth that you can follow that's been
posted in the chat and it just explains
all these different sections from the
planning application eligibility ranking
and then the implementation as well and
I'll mention a little bit about the
implementation towards the end of this
presentation as well and how the
reimbursement program works and some of
the things I like to recommend to a lot
of the farmers to implement the
practices and not go Belly Up and afford
to do the good the good conservation
work as well
um
so as mentioned
almost every county has an nrcs office
in there but there are going to be a few
scenarios where there's not an office
there and
with how an RCS programs work it's very
personal and it's based on your
operation so we need to go out to your
operation really to help you you know we
can talk to you at our desk and say
here's what we think you need but we
ultimately can't make that decision
until we go out to your specific Farm
Ranch or you know Forest stand so
if you're unsure of where your office is
located you can follow that link to find
it you can just match it to what county
you're located in and go from there
once you find where your office is
located
you can then fill out a uh see what we
call a CPA 1200 or for simple purposes
it's our application that you can fill
out and you can actually go into the
office and fill it in at the office and
we can make sure we can kind of line you
up make recommendations of you know how
who you need to go and see and where you
would need to go and one thing nrcs did
just Implement recently is we now do
have applications and other contract
documentation in multiple language so
um you know in most cases the staff will
hand a application in English but if you
are looking for another language just
let that local field staff know and they
can get you an application in another
language and there's numerous I want to
say it's I don't even know how many
total languages but there are a lot of
languages that the application forms are
offered in now
after that
um if you haven't already you I guess
it's it's up to you how you you would
want to proceed
um you can come to our office at any
time and we can take an application but
one thing we will need from you is we
will need you to go to the Farm Service
Agency so FSA and register with them and
uh if you ever have any issues on that
paperwork you can either go to them or
we can help you fill out a lot of that
information because it can be a little
complicated and you know there is a lot
of red tape but it is necessary and all
the information
um that FSA collects or nrcs collects we
don't share with anyone we um view that
as very important information and it's
very personal so when you apply you
don't need to worry about
um any identity theft or anything like
that because we will protect your
information and we're not going to share
it with anyone else around the country
so after you go through that process of
filling in an application you know as
Ellie mentioned um it's good to get an
RCS out there right away
and um then we can go out to your
property we can walk around with you we
can identify what your specific concerns
are and we can also identify additional
concerns as well
um you know as I mentioned some of the
resource concerns we're going to be
looking at Are soil water air plant and
animal and obviously we go a lot more in
depth than that um as elliemann as Ellie
was talking you know for soil we do
stuff with soil Health but if it's water
we'll do work with water quantity water
quality things of that nature and real
quick just taking a step back one thing
I did want to mention is we do take
applications year-round we do have set
deadlines that are established every
year but regardless of a time you can
come into our own office and submit an
application for for possible funding and
we'll just roll you into when the next
sign up occurs and work with with you in
that ranking process so never hesitate
to submit an application for nrcs
programs you know our door is always
open
um
so going into the programs and these are
true with any of our programs uh whether
it be equip or CSP
um
who is eligible to apply for our
programs as you can see on the screen it
varies from an individual just based on
your social security number it could be
a legal entity if you're in a
corporation or a partnership it could be
a joint operation we do help the tribes
if they wish to sign up there are some
different rules and
um in some areas I know in New Mexico
this is a very big deal our water
management entities are very influential
and historic in the state of New Mexico
and simply put a water management entity
is a governing body that has
jurisdiction over water usage and they
can actually enter into a contract with
an RCS to improve water distribution for
their property so it could actually
impact most multiple people so just keep
in mind that a sakias and irrigation
districts are eligible for our funding
but in most cases it's either going to
be your individual visual or legal
entity
another important aspect of our programs
is control of land and specifically when
it comes to control of land
nrcs can enter into a contract with one
or more participants that have control
of the offered land and when we talk
control of land it doesn't necessarily
mean you have to own that land but you
can also be renting that land and then
also depending on how you're planning
your contract you don't have to show
control for the entire length of the
contract so if you're in a year-to-year
lease like a lot of renters are
we you can update that at least every
year and still be eligible for
Contracting so don't feel like you
wouldn't be eligible if you don't own
the land or you don't have you know a
five-year lease that doesn't matter we
look at control of land every single
year so just remember that you know it
can be at least you know at least rent
or a permit and when I say permits
that's relating to federal land whether
it be BLM Bia or I should say Bureau of
Land Management Bureau of Indian Affairs
um those Acres can be included as well
um next I'm talking about land types
specifically and when I say land types
it's pretty much how the land is used
and just to give you an idea on a some
of the eligible land types that nrcs
will contract on is we do have crop land
which can either be rural like in the
photo on the right on the top or it can
be just your conventional lag as on the
right and uh I know I saw a few mentions
of
um silviculture and trees and we do lump
in that type of land use into the crop
fund pool so there is some flexibility
when it comes to that a few of the other
eligible land uses are pasture which is
irrigated and grazed by livestock
rangeland which is grazed by livestock
which is a term used in the western USA
for where the cattle Grays we do have
Forest industrial or non-industrial and
when we say forest it was historically
Forest land and that's where we do a lot
of fire management practices and even
some grazing practices if it's grazed
force and then also Association
Associated Agland and farmsteads
so after we identify that you are
eligible for our programs we do go into
a ranking process sadly not everybody is
funded in the program but there is a set
amount of dollars set aside for those
practices
so I won't go in depth because there's a
few other things I want to review
um later on and specifically it's on
what we call historically underserved
applications and when we use this term
it's members of groups have been
historically underserved or have been
subject to discrimination in federal
programs so it was actually set dollars
for these producers and it's actually at
a higher cost share rate as well and a
socially disadvantaged individual
um or entity is a member
excuse me individual or industry who is
a member of a socially disadvantaged
group socially disadvantaged groups
consist of the following so American
Indians are Alaskan native Asians black
or African-Americans native Hawaiians or
Pacific Islanders and Hispanics
um sadly
um just being female alone doesn't
qualify for socially disadvantaged these
are just rules that were set in policy
but it's still important to know if you
qualify for any of these
um another
common one that I think we're going to
see happening more often with Urban
agriculture is uh beginning Farmers so
someone who hasn't farmed a ranch for uh
more than 10 years if you qualify for
that you actually receive a higher
payment rate than you would normally and
then the veteran farmer and Rancher is
just a beginning farmer that has veteran
status
and then the last one is the limited
resource farmer Rancher and
um with director indirect gross sales
not more than the current index value in
each of the previous two years and who
has a total household income at or below
the National Poverty Level level for
family a four or less than 50 percent of
the county median household income in
each of the previous two years so those
are just some of the terms that um you
know it's important that you guys
remember that you're eligible for those
programs or eligible for those
definitions
um and then I guess what we can do is I
did provide a few links as mentioned and
if people have specific questions about
um the payment process I can cover that
uh later on just so we can keep things
rolling along so at that um that's just
a very fast rundown of our programs
yes thank you so much Aaron and I I
appreciate you also keeping it brief I
know that that is a lot of information
and I'm sure for the audience to receive
as well and for our interpreter
um who's asked us in the chat um as we
right now enter into the question and
answer part of this Workshop this is
really for you all who've joined us
taking time out of your day
um if you have questions directly for
some of our speakers or more generalized
questions what you could do is raise
your hand and then come off mute
um
by you know the the first to to raise
their hands and we'll make sure to get
through everyone also if you'd like to
you're more than welcome to put your
question in the chat
um and my friends and our
co-presentative Serafina is gonna help
me keep track of all of the different
questions
um I do see one right now and uh just to
remind ourselves when we ask these
questions if we can
keep a conversational piece for
interpretation uh that way some of these
questions you may have others who are
joining on our Spanish Channel or who
will be watching the recording recording
later can also keep track thank you all
I do see
um adiola and maybe you could say how
you pronounce your name I definitely
want to say it right
yeah thank you guys for this Workshop um
you pronounced it correctly adiola is my
name
um and my question is
um in regards to the last speaker if he
could answer this question I have
applied for I don't know if you guys can
answer this question but I've applied
for um an equip program in my state and
I followed all the procedures that you
mentioned however and I actually applied
before the deadline for my particular
State maybe a few days before because
that was when I learned about it but I
haven't heard anything back from them
what would you suggest that will be my
next steps because I've reached out to
the person that was in my that was my
contact uh twice she did reply me once
but I have yet to hear back from her so
I wanted to find out what should be my
next steps should I contact her again or
should I go up to the office or what
should I do
yeah so in the and thanks for your
question so in that scenario I know it
can be frustrating when they haven't
um responded back to you I what you need
to do is kind of multi you kind of need
to be a little bit of persistent a bit
of thorn in our side if we're not
responding to you I would show up at the
office I'd call us you know if you don't
even get anywhere there if you use that
locator that was mentioned you can
actually look at
um contacting people higher up the chain
as well if you do find that that field
office isn't responding to you I mean
ideally they should uh be responding to
you as soon as possible but I would
start becoming a bit of a squeaky wheel
and making sure you're being heard and
um you know again it can get complicated
for a lot of our staff when it's
continuous sign up because they just
want to focus on here's what I'm working
on at this point in time but in reality
we need to be
um consistently taking applications and
consistently how helping people
thank you so much I just didn't want to
seem like a nuisance but I've heard from
you and I've also heard from Ellie
thanks Ellie for your response
kind of just one thing I'd add is that
it's hard I know in New Mexico a lot of
our offices are understaffed and there's
like so and I work in an understaffed
office so not nrcs but I feel for staff
who's overwhelmed and we have to get
responses but just you know because
we're often friends with our local folks
in the offices it reminds us like Linda
why aren't you going to talk to us we
recently found out there was like a
multiple month turnaround to get a Farm
Service number which in my mind is like
a week turn around kind of thing
um and then also I think Aaron it can be
helpful now like depending on how things
work in your state but it can be a
couple months between when you put in an
application their batching period And
when they're actually deciding who
they're offering contracts to so asking
the office their timeline can help you
have more clear expectations of when
they're actually blowing you off or they
just are like we have no information and
I would just say you know echoing it's
hard it's hard patience persistence game
y'all got this
yeah and to add to that
um
as well
um oh I lost my train of thought you can
go ahead sorry whoever had questions
next
well could I just jump in here really
quick
um I just want to say I super appreciate
that um everyone's being so
straightforward about what we have to do
but um I I also just want to lift this
up as a national policy issue
um and that the the amount of
gatekeeping on funding
um is is hugely problematic and we need
to untie the hands of our our friends at
these offices
um so that they can push funding out
quicker
um and we have an opportunity maybe on
the farm bill or just any chance that we
have I think to get in front of decision
makers
um we need to be talking about this
because we shouldn't have to go into the
office we shouldn't have to wait months
and months like we're trying to Steward
land and solve climate and address
climate change and it we can't take
excuses that people are just too busy
um especially when you're a farmer
someone giving you that is that excuse
like falls on pretty like closed ears so
like I said I appreciate Aaron and you
know Sarah Gina being so honest but um
yeah and and like Hector says the
funding's there we just have to like
make it flow
yeah and just to speak to that as well
we the field staff can only control so
much when it gets to them and what my
comment was going to be is timelines
deadlines and all that information vary
from state to state so you really need
to be in contact with your local state
but in general we post all of our
information online of when our ranking
deadline is so you can always go to the
nrcs State website and see when those
deadlines are and um
from there
um it also established application
deadlines ranking deadlines and it gives
you all that information so we have to
post those deadlines you know 30 days
prior to when they occur so at the same
time as nrcs needs to help
um some of the people applying need to
be on the spot as well and understand
what they're applying for and have all
their Affairs in order so if information
is missing that slows us down but
um definitely you know we can only
control so much of where money is spent
and where it isn't and for people that
feel like they're not getting funded
um you really need to talk to your local
work groups so a lot of those
conservation districts that help nrcs
establish where our dollars are spent so
it's not as simple as we can just say oh
you want to put in a high tunnel here's
some money you know we do have to go
through a process and sadly we're not
able to establish those process
processes
um to get you funding but um I know
field staff isn't intentionally trying
to ignore you or not treat your concerns
but um please continue just to work with
your local field staff and if it does go
on silent years
um you know eventually start looking at
some of the highers higher up in the
states and your State office employees
and we'll also share a little more
um at the end of this presentation our
efforts to
um really influence and push the nrcf's
offices I did want to address and I
heard it come up in that question and
some of the responses I want to
um before going to the person with their
hand raised I think these questions
could be answered maybe as you know
they're along the similar line of
thought
um how often is funding made available
and if you don't get funded when you
apply are you able to the following year
and then I guess along with that um
Hector asked
uh where do you find the grant cycles
for all of the programs
um
and that way people can apply within
those cycles and I think you know Aaron
you partly addressed this in sharing
that it really is State specific
um
but if you could speak to ways that
people can keep track of that in um so
that they don't miss the application and
Grant Cycles
um and I think also along with that
um how long do you have to be
established to be able to apply for
those okay yep so I'll just go right
down the list of the comments of how
often is funding made available so it
really depends but in general we do
funding applications individually for
each program so it does happen every
single year now in the scenario you
don't rank high enough to get the
funding
um you will be sent a letter asking
would you like to defer your application
into the next year so if you do choose
to defer that application it will be
rolled over into the following year but
what I would encourage you if you're
constantly applying and not getting
funding talk to your field staff about
treating additional or additional
resource concerns that they found on
your property because in general the
more resource concerns you treat the
higher likelihood you have to be funded
so if you're uh just coming in every
year saying all I want is a high tunnel
I don't want anything else you're you're
not going to have as high of options to
get funding if you were planning a cover
crop to treat soil health or if you're
doing pollinator habitat you're treating
more resource concerns so definitely be
flexible in what you're willing to do
and you know if you really need to get
funded you might have to treat those
additional resource concerns as well and
then going into the next um
question was on the grant Cycles
um
we have a continuous sign up as I
mentioned so bring your application to
the office right away uh when you want
to apply for our programs and then if
you are curious about when our deadlines
are I encourage you to link to your
local State nrcs website where we are
required to post when our deadlines are
it's a federal law that we let everyone
know when those occur and um you know
they're publicly seen
so when it comes to
um officially established we don't have
any requirements on how long you have to
be in operation in order to be eligible
for our programs
um regardless of type of operation the
size of your operation location or the
overall income of your operation that
doesn't matter as long as you fill out
our application you go and get eligible
with the FSA you will be able to apply
for our programs now specifically when
it starts getting into uh work with
irrigation we do have to identify
irrigation history and you would have to
have irrigated those
um acres for two out of the last five
years
and specifically with that comment as
well when it comes to cropland is it has
to be active cropland it can't be just
grassland that you're going to farm you
need to be actively farming that land at
the time you apply and then you'd be
eligible for our cropland practices
so I'm just going to emphasize what
Aaron said If you're trying to break
fallow ground and you want nrcs
practices on that land you do that first
and maybe wait a year so when they come
to the site visit they're like yeah this
looks like agriculture as opposed to it
looks like foul land I want help on yeah
yeah and to go in depth we can't convert
land to something else that it isn't you
know we do have set guidelines and we're
not trying to you know put more acres
into production because just
um production by itself isn't a resource
concern we treat
foreign
thank you and we have a
we have a hand raise if you want to come
off mute
hi this is chido
I'm the equity program manager from
California Association of rcds
I
oh I'm located in San Jose in California
Santa Clara County and in our County we
have
130 Asian farmers in most of those Asian
farmers the Chinese Farmers Japanese
Farmers Korea farmers and Vietnamese
farmers and we are talking about a group
of people that is really isolated they
don't speak any English and they produce
they produce and then sell to the local
Asian stores so there is no English
needed for them to produce and
successful for the farm they have never
heard about anas yes they don't know
those
wonderful progress programs exists so
for the past three years
I was working as an extension specialist
and I introduced this equip program to
them and
all of them are so interested and they
want to apply so I'm asking here does
nrcs have a
kind of a brochure or kind of flyer for
different kind of problems and the
eligibility in different languages so
that I can send in this information to
those group to the group of Growers
instead of me talking to them
individually because I have my full-time
job and I am too busy to talk to each
farmers
so
and thanks for your questions
nrcs does perform a lot of Outreach in
those communities
um you know actually on another
leadership project I'm working on we are
looking at ways to improve Outreach to a
lot of those communities whether it be
on the radio or specifically go into
their meetings what I would encourage
yourself to do is reach out to the local
field staff and have them come and give
a presentation at you know I'm meeting
you organized to reach those producers
because for nrcs it's very hard to
reduce or reach out to a lot of the
people
um you know because we're so busy with
uh programs and other technical
assistance so work with your local staff
to put on events and RCS can host events
and we can gear it towards specific
communities as well to improve that
Outreach because I would agree and RCS
does need to do a better job
um you know letting people know that
we're here and that we can help anyone
yeah you know regardless of where
they're at or who they are
okay thank you Aaron for your uh answer
and I have a small little answer uh
question tip are those funding that the
Growers receiving do they have to pay
tax
yes they do technically they do got it
got it yeah and real quick on that
comment as well nrcs programs when it
comes to equip we cost share
um the cost share is meant to only be a
75 cost share so keep in mind that when
people apply for nrcs programs we're not
necessarily going to pay for everything
included we're only going to pay for a
portion of that cost so it is important
that um
you're aware and who's ever applying is
aware that there might be some monetary
requirement on whoever is applying
you guys have so many good questions and
you're going to go so far with this I'm
going to add One Word of Wisdom I was on
Medicaid when I first applied and I had
to really calculate like will this 1099
mess up my eligibility so I can stay on
Medicaid no it didn't because that's how
we're living at that point but for
anyone who's you know a part of one of
those programs you want to really Eyes
Wide Open is my
Mike um General phrase on how to
approach all of this because there's so
many benefits you just want to make sure
um there's you don't get tripped up once
you sign that contract you want to be
really ready and know you can implement
it because if you can't there can be
penalties and challenges but overall
we're hoping everyone finds a way to
have a positive experience and
especially pre appreciate everyone who's
getting this out to communities who
don't have as much access so amazing
questions
um we're going to move on to the next
segment of our agenda but I just want to
say it's been really fun to visit with
all of you and I'm I'm hoping everyone
gets into all the programs and gets all
the support that they hope for and need
Anna I'll pass it to you
yes and I keep inviting inviting
questions that we will have again all of
the speakers put their contact
information in the chat especially if
you have I can hear a lot of questions
geared toward Aaron I would really also
encourage you to look up and reach out
to your local nrcs office and feel free
as well to reach out to myself
um and our water director Aaron who's
going to be sharing a little of
um how we are working to shift and shift
the needle and see changes
um in nrcs programming and alongside the
farm bill in USDA um so Aaron if you
want to kick us off
yeah thanks Anna and thanks so much to
Serafina and Aaron and Ellie for being
here to share about these programs
um like Anna said I'm just gonna be
talking a little bit about the work that
National young Farmers Coalition is
doing
um
on nrcs programs on water and climate
issues so I'm just gonna share a little
bit about what we do we do have a water
campaign called generations for water at
National Farmers coalition
before I go into that just wanted to
share a little bit for those of you who
may not be too familiar with national
young Farmers Coalition just who we are
and what we do we are a Grassroots
network of over 200 000 Farmers ranchers
uh supporters Advocates and we are
working to shift power and change policy
to more equitably we resource the new
generation of working farmers and we
envision a just future where farming is
free of racial violence accessible to
communities oriented towards
environmental well-being and connected
with health over profit
so that's just a little bit about the
work that we're doing at nationally on
Farmers Coalition it includes our water
work we also work on land access
climate economic Justice student loan
debt so if you're interested in getting
involved in some of those other
campaigns we can plug you into those as
well but I am going to focus uh just a
bit on our water work which is most
connected with these nrcs programs
we believe that water systems should
foster vibrant agricultural communities
healthy ecosystems and water Justice for
indigenous communities and other
communities of color so when we're
looking at public policy we want public
policy that's going to be protecting
water for agriculture supporting on-farm
conservation I can get Serve and Protect
our Clean Water Resources programs like
equip that Aaron has been talking about
and ensuring access to clean drinking
water
so we do this in a number of ways water
issues can be Super Hyper local it can
be really International it's Global well
we hear a lot the challenges that young
farmers are facing are related to
Drought flooding and water quality
issues so we work on policy but we know
that can't be solved through federal
policy alone so we also work to build
farmer leadership we put on educational
events like this and foreign
Partnerships to support Farmers to be
leaders in water policy and
conservations so I just want to tell you
a little bit about what that looks like
in practice for our farmer leadership
work we run Fellowship programs I saw a
few of our water fellows on here to do
more in-depth training on water issues
at the state and federal level and
support young farmers and ranchers and
bike farmers and ranchers to not just
learn about these issues but step into
leadership positions where they can be
decision makers on our water policy
we do educational workshops like this
one we've got another one coming up next
week that I'll talk a little bit more
about so if you just want some
information on what are the resources
available to you we'll be keeping in
touch about different educational
workshops that we have going on and then
we do a lot of policy work right now
we're focused on the farm bill I think
Ellie mentioned that a little bit the
farm bill is kind of the big big federal
policy piece on food and farm programs
that's happening this year Congress is
starting to rewrite that so we're going
to be working a lot on Farm Bill
advocacy and then we also work on access
and accountability to USDA so I heard a
little bit of feedback here on how
accessing those nrcs programs have been
going so we can help with that help hold
USDA and nrcs accountable to the
commitments that they've made and
provide feedback on how those programs
are working for young farmers
um so here are some ways that you can
stay in touch with us
um this is our first Workshop in a short
Series this um
this spring on how to use federal
resources
um to support conservation and also
manage risk when it comes to Drought
floods freezes we're going to be talking
more about those disaster programs next
week
um Anna I think he's gonna throw in the
chat the registration for that next
Workshop if you're interested in
um Federal programs that can help you
support you if there's a disaster and
then we're going to be putting on our
third workshop on world water day
that'll be more celebratory connecting
networking and getting to know you all a
little bit more in March for World water
day
another way to stay
um involved with us and is touch is work
with us to connect with your local and
state nrcs leaders Aaron mentioned you
can connect with your field staff you
can connect with staff at the state
level or federal level too so if you
have feedback that you want to provide
on how those programs are going let us
know and we're happy to help you make
those connections
um we've got a few other resources we
have a national survey report that has
more information on young Farmers across
the country the water challenges that
they're facing and how they're
addressing those so check out our survey
report
you can also share your own story and if
you don't see that included in this
survey Anna is awesome at helping you
lift up your story whether that's with
local policy makers your members of
Congress your local nrcs office the
Press if you have a short story you want
to share around water connect with Anna
and we can help you do that
we're also going to have some more
Fellowship cohorts coming up I mentioned
we do water Fellowship programs to
support farmer leadership so keep in
touch we're going to have a new one
we're planning to launch towards the end
of this year
and then uh last if you want to work
with us especially on Farm Bill advocacy
we have a place where you can sign up uh
let us know and you'll be getting more
information
there and Anna's gonna throw that link
in the chat
um so that's the best way to stay in
touch with what's happening at Young
farmers and with our water campaign
and just so you know who to talk to
um we've got a small M ID team on our
water team I'm our water director Anna
is our water organizer and we also have
a fellowship coordinator Megan Davey who
I think I saw on this call Will through
our contact information in the chat if
you want to be in touch and I think
that's all I have and I will pass it
back to you to wrap us up
thank you to all of our speakers they
provided
so much valuable information and also to
everybody who joined from across the
country it's so incredible to see people
doing amazing work even from what I can
tell in the chat and
um yeah I wish to have more time with
each of you especially if you're
interested I hear a lot of feedback for
nrcs and they need to hear it directly
from you
um we have organizers across the country
in different states who are working to
set up
meetings uh there's folks like Hector a
California organizer on the call
um but I would suggest California folks
reaching out to if you don't already
know Hector those are our opportunities
when we go and meet with nrcs staff just
like our Congress people these are
decision makers and folks who can
communicate up the line to USDA staff
What would we need to see both in the
farm bill and in the offices across the
country to make it more accessible for
all of you to use and harness these
programs and the funding that is out
there and I hope that you all are able
to I hope this was uh valuable
information that you're able to walk
away with um and if there's questions
like I said this is not our last
opportunity to connect
um
you have several times my contact
information the other speakers as well
um if you'd like to stay up to date we
will have a newsletter that link is
posted in the chat
um
as well I encourage you all to reach out
to others at Young Farmers those you've
met on the call
um and continue doing the amazing work
again thank you all for joining us and I
hope to see you next week or you know to
share like I said feel free to share any
of the information and recordings from
this workshop with others you think will
benefit
um
good luck with all of your endeavors and
I hope you all have a beautiful rest of
your day
thank you